Good news, scientists discovered a virus that
makes you dumber.
Wait, that’s bad news!
I screwed up, don’t roll the intro…
Hey Guys, I’m Joe guest hosting for DNews.
Scientists from the University of Nebraska
working in conjunction with scientists from
Johns Hopkins Medical School were getting
their science on while studying the wonderful
world of throat microbes, when they accidently
stumbled upon a microorganism that they believe
literally makes people, to put it delicately…
stupid.
The virus is known as chlorovirus ATCV-1 and
they discovered it inside the throats of 40
out of 92 volunteers, but before this study,
science only found the stuff lurking in green
algae kicking it in freshwater lakes.
Now, researchers have yet to figure out how
chlorovirus ATCV-1 migrates from our lakes
and streams to the moist safe-haven of human
throats, if it migrates at all, they are not
sure how it gets inside, but once it is, the
microorganism is like that kid down the street
that your parents didn’t want you playing
with because he had an affinity for the sound
of breaking glass and fire and was a straight
up bad influence that made you more dumberer…
After infiltrating and swabbing the throats
of the 92 participants the researchers proceeded
to subject the volunteers to a number of cognitive
tests, measuring attention span as well as
speed and accuracy in visual processing.
And low and behold, the 44% carrying chloroviurs
ATCV-1 scored an average of 7-9 points lower,
totally disappointing their overbearing parents
in the process.
I’m not dumb, dad!
My body is just home to a brain-altering microorganism
that ravages my intelligence.
Jeez!
I’m outta here.
I’m gonna go hang out with Ryan Jacobi.
We’re gonna throw rocks at windows and light
a tree stump on fire.
To double-check the findings, the scientists
did what scientists tend to do, and experimented
on unsuspecting mice, injecting a bunch of
Stewert Little’s with ATCV-1 and placed
them in a mouse maze, and they got dumb.
The stupid juice seeped into the hippocampus
and scrambled memory formation and learning
pathways, making it increasingly difficult
for the mice to navigate the labyrinth and
get accepted into mouse Harvard.
Now, this is super interesting for a number
of reasons, but here’s the thing, our bodies
are slathered, inside and out, with all sorts
of microorganisms, and most are innocuous,
but this study showcases that even though
our immune systems may not be affected by
a tiny intruder, our cognitive functions may
still fall victim to their exploits.
So, the body stays strong while the mind secretly
withers away.
Dr. Robert Yolken, co-author of the study
said, “On average, people with the virus
had perhaps a 5–10 percent decrease in the
domains [of brain function] we measured.
That’s probably not noticeable in day-to-day
conversation or activity, but is significant.”
Taking things a step further, science will
try to understand the subtle effects of all
the tiny hitch-hikers on our bodies and will
most certainly try to discover ways to alter
the microorganism make up inside us to make
us not just healthier, but smarter as well.
Cool.
So do you think you have the stupid virus
or know someone who does?
Tell us about it down in the comments below
and don’t forget to subscribe for more DNews
every day of the week.